hi everyone welcome back to Art of the
part I'm out in the shop today and I'm
making a run of our 98 432 components
for the students uh they're going to
look something like
this so we're making this little kit so
that we can measure 98431 9843 2 and
then
98433 and then we'll do some measurement
and quality control exercises on these
as well as drawing them and Cad and Cam
and then running them out in the
machine I just wanted to walk through a
little bit of first operation and how I
would approach this so I'm here on the
dmu 50 from DMG Mory I'm going to pop
here into my CNC control and what I
would normally do is I would just double
check or maybe even write this program
uh I've been running uh a handful of
these prior to this but I'm just going
to go through this uh and talk about it
we wrote this program here in shop Mill
which is is the conversational program
software embedded into these Seaman
controls so this is the Seaman 840d
controller and the way that I wrote this
so I'm going to go over here to my
program
manager I have a set here and I just
want to call out a couple things um so
we have first stop machine block zero uh
first stop machine block 1 2 3 and then
we also have the sub program here for
98420 so I'm going to jump over here to
my first stop machine block 2 which
should be for the backside of the 98 432
component and you can see that it's
pretty simplified here uh we have a
handful of conversational program
commands here that we wrote in so if I
go in here to my program header we're
just trying to Center um our CMM probe
we're touching off with that renesha uh
Ruby tip probe here uh to establish our
work offset so we're calling out a work
offset of G5 10 uh we're just going to
do a block centered so when I cycle
start this a probe is going to come out
and it's going to touch uh points in X
and Y and then establish them uh as a
center point of the raw stock material
this is pretty helpful because I'm not
picking up the same uh cut length of
material every single time uh we're just
cutting this on a a regular saw so it
could vary anywhere up from like 60,000
to an eigh of an inch so we're not super
exact so it's helpful to call out this
uh little workof set touch off to
establish the center of that block uh
our working material is going to be
around three uh and a qu or sorry 3 and
3/4 in uh X and then 3 in and Y so we
added a little bit of stock here to the
uh X Dimension and we'll go down through
that accept that then we would go ahead
and measure an edge so we're trying to
touch off on the z0 establish it as z0
for that work off set 510 um we'll call
it off again we're giving it a rough
idea of where it is in relation to uh
the existing um work offet cancel that
out and then we'll measure out that
rectangle to get the uh exact center of
the uh piece of material that's in there
right now so couple pieces there it
takes a while to go through this and
I'll cyle start it and we'll we'll start
going through it here but we also wrote
some pretty easy uh lines of code so we
did a face maill just finish we're
giving it its X and Y extents and how
far it has to go down and
z uh then we're going to do a
rectangular spigot which is just going
to go around uh in a rectangular pattern
this is our roughing this is our
finishing you can see that we have a
roughing icon there finishing icon there
and then we use the same uh geometry
there to go ahead and do a chamfer then
we'll engrave the part number and then
we'll engrave the uh name of the part
and then we actually execute this
subprogram so you can see there that
98420 that was back in that other folder
um this is something I programmed in
master cam it's just a logo it's the IIT
logo that it's going to be on the back
of each one of these
components so it's going to be that um I
mean I'm I'm pretty good at writing
G-Code but I don't think I can write
that by hand or if I would it would just
take way too long so that's why I just
made that as a master cam program and
then just call it up as a sub program
and each one of these so pretty simple
um as I go through 98431 984 32 98433 I
just copy this program and then change
some of these parameters so this reads
the appropriate machine block uh so
pretty simple um I would always go ahead
and run this as a simulation before
running apart so I'll simulate that out
we'll see what this looks
like okay so touching off on the probe
cutting around
it there's our finishing
pass uh the champer tool and then we're
going to engrave this might take a a
little bit to get through so I'm going
to program control see if I can 100%
override sometimes it'll go
faster uh with this override I've often
run into issues where there's too much
code that it actually slows down when
you do you know 100% over ride let's see
if I can go any faster here okay so we
got our rough idea of this it'll take a
second to go ahead and like uh render
this out but you can trust me that
that's what that oh there it is that's
what that program looks
like and then we'll jump back here into
our program and then we can see that
there's an estimated total time of 5
minutes and 30 seconds so I'm pretty
happy with this we're going to go ahead
and execute um but before we do I'm
going to unload the part because I have
the been running production so I'm going
to go ahead and do that unload it make
sure you're wearing your safety goggles
we're going to open the door
slightly I'm going to blow this
off all
right and that's what the finished
product is going to look like um we can
see that it is fully secured in the vice
and it's sitting here on the teeth of
the vice so there's no parallels beneath
it so I'm going to go ahead and grab my
torque
wrench and then I'm going to loosen
this
okay normally when I have two hands I
would go ahead and blow this off as well
uh but I'm just going to bring this over
here and take a couple quick
measurements I could put it on the
surface plate and measure this but we
also have the flashing of the material
the raw material
so I think it's just easier for us to go
ahead and measure this out with a
caliper so here I'm at
zero so I'm just going to go ahead and
measure this so we should be reading 3
and 1/2 so we're a little large just
about a half a tenth not a big deal
still within our plus or minus 3,000
tolerance and then we'll go ahead and
grab this side and then we're about 3/10
so again we're still in our uh plus or
minus or sorry that's 3,000 so this
might be a little tight I'm going to go
ahead and try it again here a little
hard to measure here with one hand so
I'm now seeing about 1,000 little bit
more accurate there I just double check
this
side okay yeah I'm at 1,000 sorry I
called that cap of 10th so again we're
in our plus orus 3,000
so this should be good to go and run
another program and set this up for a
second operation but I'm going to take a
piece of raw material here I'm going to
load this in the teeth and the way that
we wrote that program for the probe uh
we just have to Center this somewhere
here in the Vie it doesn't have to be
exact but as long as we Center it by eye
we should be good to call that out
normally with two hands I would hold
this down and then clamp um but this
torque wrench is set to 75 newm so it
should click when we hit that pressure
or that Force so we got that click I
don't have to uh tighten this down any
further so that should be
good we don't have to use a dead blow
hammer uh cuz then we'd end up damaging
the teeth so I think we're pretty good
there so we confirmed that the program
is good I'm going to go ahead and lock
the door I'm going to select execute
sorry we're going to select execute
checked out this program and we can see
there uh that the program is now loaded
into uh the machine the control panel
and we can go ahead and cycle start this
uh since I've been running a handful of
these like a full run of them I've been
letting this run at 100% on the uh rapid
as well as the linear however if this is
the first part that we're going to be
running for the day I'm going to
encourage you to turn these both down
and likewise while you're operating the
machine always keep a hand near your e
stop or your Cycle Stop to stop the
program stop the machine in case the
Tool uh gets too close to the workpiece
the table or sorry the um the visce or
the table uh so that we don't uh have a
crash so we're good to go I'm going to
go ahead and cycle start
this we can see that when we cycle
started it's going to try to do a tool
change um it's calling out you know some
distance to go here we also get this
warning that there needs some kind of
feed rate uh before we can get going so
so I have to turn up my rapid here to
cycle this tool change so once I turn
this up that's going to turn
green so we see that green we can see
that the tool change is
cycling so with this conversational
program it's running like an M6 command
in the background however um because it
is here in shop Mill uh it's going to go
ahead and probe this out so I would
always encourage you to run your probe
at 100%
um rapid just so that you get an
accurate
amount okay and then we also are looking
for 100% on our feed so rapid sorry 100%
on our linear so we see another warning
here so this is g0 g01 it's asking for
g01 right now so I'm going to turn this
up to
100 so we're touching that off taking a
couple points it's right now we're just
trying to establish the center of the
park okay so we should have gotten X
there and now we're going to go ahead
and grab
y so again this is a uh
conversational programming piece inside
of shop Mill very specific to the dm50
as well as the uh Seaman's 840d
controller now we're going to
grab uh the next tool so we're cycling
that out so now we're moving into that
face Milling operation so here's where I
would encourage you to go ahead and
again turn both of these down as well as
always keep a hand near your EOP so as
we're doing that tool change we can see
that the tool has turned on it is
rotating but we get a warning that it's
asking for some kind of heat so I'm
going to turn my coolant off it's just
good habit to make sure that I'm making
good contact with the top of the face of
my z0 that we just established um
because if I miss the pass or the pass
is too deep uh I can go ahead and stop
the program before we cut any further so
I'm going to ease my tool in with my
rapid feed
rate okay so we're moving over the
part slow this down a little
bit okay we can also see our distance to
go so we're at 0 0 now it has to travel
an X so it's ask me to turn on a new
feed so this is going to be our uh
linear so we are not going to be able to
control this anymore with the rapid it
has reach the end of its g0000 commands
so we're going to turn that down we're
going to turn this up this is our g01
and we're going to see if this is going
to hit the part so I'm turning my my
linear feed rate
on see if we make
contact okay so I'm seeing some chips
looks like we are making contact if I so
wish I can go ahead and turn my coolant
back
[Music]
on and I'll let this run
through okay so again it's ask me for
some uh feed rate here so it's reached
the end of a g01 command so I'm going to
turn that off I'm going to turn on my g0
can also turn off my coolant here and
this is probably just going to retract
out all right so we're retracting out
we're doing a tool change for the 5/8
End Mill you can see here it's changing
from the 3-in face Mill to the 5/8 End
Mill this is our roughing tool I'll go
ahead and cycle this all the way through
the tool change to speed that up a
little bit but when the Tool comes out
I'm going to go ahead and turn this all
the way down so tool is coming out and
then I turned it all the way down so
it's stationary it's stuck in place it's
asking me for a feed rate going to go
ahead and turn this
up and this would be a good chance for
us to go through this turn down my make
sure that your uh linear fade is off and
again cannot State this enough but
always have a hand near your stop or
your um Cycle Stop just in case that we
get a little bit too close we got to
make any changes to the program don't
want to damage the machine don't want to
damage the tool and and do not want to
damage the work piece I'm going to turn
my coolant off and again we're reaching
the end of
our uh rapid so I'm going to turn this
down I'm going turn my linear
[Music]
up okay so we're approaching the part
and here would be a good chance for me
to as it's going into its coner here I'm
going to turn both these off and I can
go ahead and Cycle Stop this so it's
going to interrupt the program it's not
going to cancel it we're going to open
up the door and what I would typically
do is before this makes a full cons pass
around I would come in with a
scale or ruler and make sure that I'm
not going to cut into the bites so I can
see that there's a gap here in between
the tool and the top of my vice I know
that there's going to be two passes but
at least this one pass this top pass I
feel safe with let's go ahead and
continue through with it we'll go
through this action a couple times
here so lock the door back up so again
we interrupted the program it's now
calling for a cycle start and now we
have to turn on our linear feed so we
just heard that we made contact we're
doing pretty good so we'll cut all the
way around
[Music]
once all right so now it's going to back
out and then it's going down and here
again we'll check out our distance to go
so we have to go about 20,000 more so
I'm going to turn my feet up when I see
the X and Y pop
up turn this off so I'm at my zv value
now I'm going to do that Contour uh pass
I'm going to go ahead and Cycle Stop
this once
again unlock the door and we can see
that the tool is now notice be lower
than it was before so what I'm going to
do is slide my scale in there and even
though that it's pretty close I still
have a gap I'm still within a tolerance
that I can go and make one full pass
around this with a contour without
hitting the vice and damaging uh the
machine the spindle or the tool so as
long as I see Gap there I'm happy I'm
going to go ahead and close the door
we're going to go ahead and lock it
cycle
started and then we can go ahead and
turn up our linear so we can hear that
it's going to make contact and you can
see I'm actually going to turn off the
coolant when it comes around this side
you can see how close it is to the
visce so that's why we always want to
check our Z depths so that we
accidentally don't plunge into that Vice
so I'm going to turn that coolant back
on uh we at least have some Gap in
between again the tip of the tool and
then the top of the Vise
here um I don't want to typically turn
this up anymore right now cuz I'm
already in a pass I don't want to Ru or
change the surface finish from one side
of the part to the other side of the
part so I'm going to let this finishing
pass run out like this um but that said
I'm pretty happy with this program again
I've been running a handful of them uh I
would encourage you to always run single
block or step through your program and
make sure that every single line of code
is good to go
cuz you absolutely do not want to damage
the machine you do not want to damage
your tool or damage your workpiece um so
I'm going to end the video there uh I'm
going to turn my rapid and my liter all
the way up let this run out and I'll be
probably running a handful sorry a
handful more parts of these uh but I
appreciate you watching I hope that you
learned something just talking my way
through this first operation here so uh
we'll go ahead and catch you in the next
one thanks
bye